that's big this one's big oh
saved
all right y'all so on the show i made
some amazing instagramable pancakes
you guys have got to take a bite we're
fine okay i'm taking a bite now i'm
doing it too
okay okay i'm not doing well though
what's great is like restaurants in new
york are making these la but if you want
you can just make them at home
but today i want to take it even further
by making
literal pancake art um because i don't
know how to do that but we're gonna do
it
basically it's exactly like it sounds i
use these squeeze bottles
filled with batter and i make art out of
them
i'm going to make pancake art of all the
things and people i love
or for them um ten of them in fact under
10 minutes so
start praying now okay here we go i'm
gonna start with this one
okay wait oh wait you should always do
this first that's gonna
okay here we go
i'm starting with a pink heart for my
baby girl river rose
she loves this is she loves drawing and
we're always
she always asks me to do hearts or stars
or whatever okay wait
this one's for my boy blue remy
i'm going to do a little heart for him
as well
okay i know river's going to be like why
was this bigger and i didn't mean to do
that river
it just happened so then you don't leave
it long right so
a little longer than that um and then
i'm going to do this one's for seth
our 13 year old and i'm going to make
like a little
little rectangle to do like the the
control that's always in his hands
because he's always playing
or it could be a keyboard because he's
always playing a game
that's what i'm doing there and then i'm
going to do
[Music]
for my man cuz he's royal i'm gonna do a
circle for him
because we make each other go round our
worlds
there we go okay here we go
and oh shoot
oh it's saved saved saved
that's big this one's big oh
saved wait here we go which one did i do
next okay
yeah seth yours was it's because yours
one was sorry mom
okay oh it's fine
everything's fine okay then to give a
little love
love little tears
just kidding i'm gonna make a star
wait there's the heart i don't want him
to burn okay
okay remote control remote control
whatever
okay and then wait and then
i'm gonna do oh i got it
hold on i should have made that a little
smaller
wait i'm gonna do wait oh wait
i'm gonna do this one
it's kind of amazing i don't know i'm
gonna flip this
i don't know i'm gonna flip it i'm
making a sunflower
because i love sunflowers
that's i don't know how that's gonna pan
out i'm gonna be real
it's gonna be great it's a little brown
it's a little brown um
i often bake chrissy
all my spare time okay wait i'm gonna do
refrigerator a portrait
i'll do a i'll do a rose
i'm really into flowers or
wait here we go i know i know that's my
sister's favorite flower
wait i'm not done that though watch i
know i was going to do a rose and then i
thought i already did one for river
and my kids are always like what did you
do
i don't know what that turned into you
know what let's just play now
i've already messed it up so we're going
to line it
it's a yellow chocolate covered
strawberry
it's oh no it's not
it's gonna be great it's gonna be great
look it's like a little something invite
me over i'll cook breakfast
[Music]
it's kind of great it's burning but it's
fine
okay wait i haven't used this yet
here we go whoa that one's weird
what
here we go we're gonna cover that up
it's like you know when you get a bad
tattoo
i'm just gonna make just a design that's
what i'm gonna do
oh and it's gonna be like pride check it
out
see oh i think you might be
it's fine
i bet they taste delicious let's do oh
i got it my daughter is obsessed with
rainbows these aren't all kids certainly
nobody knows
well i don't have all the proper colors
you sound like her
she's like you're not doing it right i'm
like it's my rainbow
i don't care about indigo
this is my grand finale
um challenge accepted let's do
okay
okay let's do yeah
no no
[Music]
it's a bow tie it's a bow tie
oops
[Music]
yeah let me get that rainbow
oh that looks cool there's only three
colors but whatever
still pot of gold somewhere it's great
is that that's done right yeah okay wait
look i'm on my tenth one and it's a nice
lovely bow tie
this is actually my kids would love this
i'm gonna do this
i'm gonna go to montana i've got hearts
hearts i've hidden that one it's a
little weird um i've got rainbow little
strawberry with little you know whatever
it's cute
and then a little star i think i did
great
let's just take a bite of this whatever
flag it is
i think i did all right i'm not an
artist in this sense
i just sing i can't draw or
paint or these are good though
doesn't matter how bad they look they
still taste the same i'm gonna take some
of this heart this is my heart
[Music]
cheers
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going